absolute majority of member states
states parties to direct control
conventions I firmly against
legalization of drugs a level
ministerial meeting adopted a
ministerial declaration confirming the
relevance of all three drug control
conventions actually there are some
exceptions Canada Uruguay and some state
in the United States should we have
noticed that in the United States for
instance some states where marijuana is
legalized it didn't result in stopping
the black marketer majority of NGOs are
also opposed to any attempts to legalize
drugs but is always happens the majority
is more silent than a minority
[Music]
you